en la izquierda tenemos el ciclo penta
bien y tenemos este sh2 que forma un
puente del lado derecho tenemos al bien
o filo y tenemos dos aldehídos que se
encuentran en posición cis así que en
este vídeo tenemos que tomar en cuenta
la estéreo química tanto del lleno como
la del bien o filo pero también
hablaremos de los productos endo y exo
primero pensemos en la reacción de piel
sal der sin tomar en cuenta la estéreo
química vamos a mover nuestros 6
electrones para estos electrones que se
mueven hacia acá para formar un enlace
entre estos dos carbonos estos
electrones se mueven hacia acá para
formar un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos y finalmente estos electrones
se mueven hacia abajo entonces si
dibujamos nuestro producto sin
preocuparnos por la estéreo química
ahorita aquí tenemos el doble enlace y
luego vamos a
abreviar a los grupos aldehído como se h
aquí tenemos un ch o y por acá tenemos
otro aldehído entonces se h
y finalmente vamos a poner el puente de
sh2 resaltemos los electrones los
electrones py en color rojo formaron
este enlace los electrones
en azul formaron este enlace y los
electrones py en rosa formaron este
enlace ahora al dibujar el producto no
tomamos en cuenta la estéreo química
pero como se encontrarán los aldehídos
con respecto a éste ch2 del puente bueno
supongamos que el lleno y el lleno filo
se acercan de esta manera ya sabemos que
se forma este enlace en rojo entre este
carbono y este carbono que en el
producto corresponde a este enlace
también sabemos que se forma este enlace
en color azul entre este carbono
este carbón y corresponde a este enlace
en el producto entonces primero pensemos
en la estéreo química del bien si
analizamos el ciclo penta de lleno
aquí tenemos este sh2 que ya dijimos
forma un puente y sabemos que los
sustituyen test internos van hacia
arriba miren en el modelo aquí está el
ch 2 y estos son los enlaces que se
conectan a él pero después cuando se
forma el producto el ch 2 termina hacia
arriba ahora pensemos en la estéreo
química del 10 nov y lo tenemos el doble
enlace y tenemos dos hidrógenos del lado
izquierdo si dibujamos una línea
recordemos que todo lo que tengamos del
lado izquierdo va a quedar hacia abajo
en el producto entonces estos hidrógenos
corresponden a estos hidrógenos y si
observamos el producto d
en esta perspectiva podemos ver que los
hidrógenos están lejos de nosotros
quedaron hacia abajo mientras que los
aldehídos que están representados de
color rojo podemos ver que son estos
grupos y en el producto terminan del
mismo lado entonces si observamos el
producto desde esta perspectiva los
aldehídos se encuentran hacia nosotros
así que cuando dibujamos el producto
vamos a dibujarlo tenemos un compuesto
be cíclico aquí tenemos el puente de sh2
también tenemos un doble enlace y
después tenemos a los aldehídos que como
están hacia arriba en este carbono
tenemos un aldehído hacia arriba ch
y también tenemos un hidrógeno hacia
abajo después en este carbono tenemos un
aldehído también hacia arriba
ch y después tenemos un hidrógeno hacia
abajo este es el producto exo y se le
llama exo porque tenemos a los aldehídos
hacia arriba al igual que el ch 2 del
puente y aquí tenemos el doble enlace
este es uno de los posibles productos
ahora qué pasa si el lleno filo se
acerca de esta forma bueno aquí tenemos
los hidrógenos del doble enlace y vamos
a dibujar nuestra línea recuerden todo
lo que tenemos del lado derecho del
doble enlace termina hacia arriba
observen que aquí están los dos
hidrógenos y cuando se forman estos dos
enlaces esos hidrógenos terminan hacia
arriba claro si observamos el producto
desde esta perspectiva mientras que por
otro lado todo lo que tenemos del lado
izquierdo
ahora los aldehídos están del lado
izquierdo serían estos grupos y cuando
se forma el producto y también lo vemos
desde esta perspectiva terminan hacia
abajo es decir se alejan de nosotros
entonces vamos a dibujar este producto
nuevamente tenemos un compuesto be
cíclico con un puente de sh2 el doble
enlace está por aquí y ahora los
hidrógenos se encuentran hacia arriba
así que en este carbono tenemos un
hidrógeno hacia arriba y después tenemos
un aldehído hacia abajo aquí tenemos un
ch
y lo mismo tenemos en este carbono un
hidrógeno hacia arriba y un aldehído
hacia abajo este es el producto endo
endo porque los aldehídos han quedado
hacia abajo y el ch 2 del puente está
hacia arriba y aquí tenemos el doble
enlace ahora resulta que el producto
endo es el producto favorecido a esto se
le llama regla endo y ocurre por la
interacción en
la formación del enlace pi que ocurre
entre estos dos carbonos y los grupos
carbón y los de los aldehídos que
corresponden a estas esferas de color
rojo entonces en esa interacción entre
la formación del doble enlace y los
grupos carbón y lo que lo que hacen es
estabilizar al bien o filo cuando se
acerca de esta forma y eso provoca que
los grupos aldehído queden hacia abajo
así obtenemos el producto en dos y por
eso el producto en dos es favorecido
mientras que en el producto exo éstos
aldehídos se encuentran muy lejos de la
formación del doble enlace no hay
interacción por eso el producto exo no
es favorecido
hagamos un problema más del lado
izquierdo tenemos al bien y del lado
derecho tenemos al bien off y lo vamos a
dibujar el producto sin tomar en cuenta
la estéreo química hay que mover los 6
electrones para aquí se forma un enlace
entre estos dos carbonos también se
forma un enlace entre estos dos carbonos
y estos electrones se mueven hacia abajo
entonces cuando dibujamos nuestro
producto sin tomar en cuenta la estéreo
química en este carbono tenemos un
aldehído
por acá tenemos un grupo metilo al igual
que aquí abajo sigamos a los electrones
estos electrones py en color rojo
formaron este enlace los electrones py
en color azul formaron este enlace y los
electrones py en color rosa se movieron
para formar el doble enlace ahora
resaltemos esos electrones en el modelo
molecular de la fotografía este enlace
en rojo se formó entre este carbono y
este carbón y corresponde a este enlace
en el producto después el enlace azul se
formó entre este carbono y este carbón y
corresponde a este enlace del producto
pero observe si el yen o filo se acerca
de esta manera no hay una interacción
estabilizadora entre la formación del
doble enlace y el grupo carbón hilo por
eso aquí abajo he volteado alguien o
filo para que exista un acercamiento en
ahora pensemos en la estéreo química
primero analicemos la estéreo química
del día no sabemos que los sustituyen
test internos van hacia arriba así que
estos hidrógenos en el día no terminan
hacia arriba si observamos el producto
desde esta perspectiva mientras que los
grupos metilo que son las esferas de
color amarillo los grupos metilo
terminan hacia abajo con respecto a los
hidrógenos están hacia abajo si
observamos la molécula desde la misma
perspectiva entonces vamos a dibujar el
producto aquí tenemos nuestro anillo con
un doble enlace y los grupos metilo
están lejos de nosotros así que los
podemos representar claro con líneas
punteadas ahora vamos con el bien o filo
si dibujamos nuestra línea sabemos que
todo lo que tenemos del lado izquierdo
termina hacia abajo así que este al
no termina hacia abajo vamos a ver aquí
tenemos el aldehído y sabemos que el
acercamiento en do nos da una
estabilidad entre la formación del doble
enlace y el carbón y lo entonces en
nuestro producto aquí tenemos el
aldehído y nuevamente si observamos la
molécula desde esta perspectiva éste
aldehído se encuentra lejos de nosotros
así que vamos a representarlo con una
línea punteada
qué pasa si el bien o filo se acerca de
esta manera bueno éste sigue siendo un
acercamiento endo porque aquí tenemos el
aldehído y aquí se da la formación del
doble enlace así que hay una estabilidad
por la interacción y miren aquí tenemos
el aldehído en el producto si lo
observamos desde esta perspectiva el
aldehído queda lejos de nosotros vamos a
dibujar el producto aquí tenemos nuestro
anillo el doble enlace y éste aldehído
se encuentra en este carbono así que lo
representamos con una línea punteada y
por otro lado los grupos metilo también
se alejan de nosotros vamos a dibujarlos
entonces cuál es la relación entre estas
dos moléculas bueno son enantiómero si
obtuvimos un par de enantiómero